SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> LeBRON WILL BE CHOOSING FIRST
IN THIS DRAFT.
AND KEVIN DURANT, THE LEADING
VOTE GETTER IN THE EAST, AND
WHILE HE WON'T BE ABLE TO PLAY
IN THE ALL-STAR GAME BECAUSE OF
INJURY, HE IS CAPTAIN FOR THE
SECOND STRAIGHT YEAR.
LOOKING FOR SOME PAYBACK AGAINST
MR. JAMES HERE.
KEVIN, LET ME -- LET'S JUST GET
TO THE NEWS OF THE DAY, YOU
KNOW, BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
DRAFT, BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY,
EVERYBODY TALKING ABOUT THE
TRADE DEADLINE.
AND BROOKLYN HAS TRADED JAMES
HARDEN, PAUL MILLSAP TO FP.
BEN SIMMONS AND SETH CURRY AND
ANDRE DRUMMOND COMING YOUR WAY.
YOUR INITIAL REACTION TO HEARING
THAT THIS HAD GONE DONE?
>> I'M EXCITED FOR OUR TEAM.
LOOKING FORWARD TO FINISHING THE
SEASON OUT WITH THESE NEW GROUPS
AND THESE NEW PLAYERS.
AND, YOU KNOW, PLAYOFFS RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER SO WE GOT TO
FAST TRACK TO GETTING USED TO
EACH OTHER BUT I'M EXCITED.
I THINK EVERYBODY GOT WHAT THEY
WANTED.
>> YOU KNOW, KEVIN, I GOT TO
SAY, MAN.
DO YOU HAVE A FULL-TIME
PSYCHIATRIST ON STAFF DEALING
WITH ALL OF THE STUFF YOU HAVE
TO DEAL WITH IN BROOKLYN?
>> WHAT I GOT TO DO?
I'M MAKING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PLAYING BASKETBALL.
>> I KNOW THAT BUT YOU GOT TO
DEAL WITH THE JAMES SITUATION
BUT NOT ANY MORE.
KYRIE IS GOING ON.
IT'S ALWAYS DRAMA AROUND THAT
TEAM.
SO I KNOW YOU GOT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY TO TALK TO, BECAUSE
IT'S HECTIC.
>> I LOVE MY BROTHERS,
REGARDLESS.
>> YOU KNOW, K.D., YOU KNOW, YOU
LOOK WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE ACQUIRED
AND WHAT YOU GUYS LET GO.
WITH THE JAMES, THE FLOOR WAS
SPREAD DIFFERENTLY.
NOW BEN BEING THERE, SETH, WHAT
DO YOU ENVISION IN TERMS OF WHEN
YOU COME BACK?
THE STYLE, STYLISTICALLY YOU
GUYS WILL BE DOING?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I FE